great thank you Justin so our next
speaker is quite exciting because we
have Robin rumbach who is coming to talk
to us about stable diffusion and friends
so Robin is a research scientist at
stability Ai and already is a background
in physics I think he got his PhD in
computer science at the computer Vision
Group in Heidelberg which is where a lot
of the work on things like Peak again
taming Transformers lead diffusion
models which then became stable
diffusion a lot of that work went down
so very excited to have one of the OG
authors here with us Robin thank you so
much for joining us yeah thanks for the
intro
um actually I didn't uh I don't have the
PHD yet um so I'm still affiliated with
the complex group but uh
um Okay so
I want to talk about a bit uh
of course about stability Fusion but
more about like the underlying methods
we developed
um in the research group
and also as you already mentioned uh BQ
again is closely related so I'll also
bring that up and in general I'm talking
about this um family of two-stage
generative models which stable diffusion
is one instance of
um yeah so
in general diffusion is a text to image
neural network so this means that this
model can be used to generate and also
to modify images based on text inputs
and for me it has been like really
surreal to see this uh what what people
call Cambrian explosion of creative AI
with uh thousands of I mean different
fine-tuned
um dream Booth versions of the model of
repositories that Tinker with the model
and so on it's uh it has been really uh
cool really surreal
um and maybe we want to highlighted I
just saw a few days back was uh this
object taped to the wall diffusion model
which I think is uh kind of peaky create
creativity but yeah let's uh let's look
back on how we actually got there
um
and yeah as I said establish Fusion is a
two-stage generative model and
I think one view to view this uh
two-stage generative models is that they
actually can combine domain knowledge
and a general purpose generative
modeling
um Paradigm so
um
what this means is this that the
modeling is separated into two different
uh stages which are more usually not uh
trained jointly together but uh you
first trained first state and then the
second stage so what what this gives you
is that you can actually in the first
stage design something that's that is
domain specific or data specific so it
can take in images or maybe video 3D
structures whatever you're interested in
and map this to a so-called latent
representation on which you then train a
general
um generative model in the second stage
which can be a diffuser model but also
Transformer or other things
and this means that you that you can uh
kind of separate the
generative process from the process that
requires domain knowledge
um and maybe it's a nice way to actually
collaborate with uh different
um backgrounds and so on so one instance
of this is this uh Leon model which is a
latent diffusion model for 3D shape
generation uh dude like I think this was
published yesterday or two days ago it's
a latent space diffusion models of
cryo-em structures
um for structural biology modeling and
actually another instance of that is uh
dolly two
um and this is like
what stable diffusion is also about is
um
actually
um
using domain knowledge of the image
domain to compress
images into a lower dimensional space in
which it is very easy to actually do
generative modeling so uh Dolly 2 uses
clip which is uh contrastively trained
model to compress input images into the
slow dimensional um
Vector space and then they train a
diffusion prior on this Vector space to
kind of invert this process
um
so
why why is it actually important to
incorporate this domain knowledge when
you want to model uh images
um and let me maybe try to explain this
with uh this example here this image of
the scribble
um so if
but but when we're interested in doing
generative modeling of such images are
it is important to capture the global
structure of the image but we're usually
not that interested in modeling all the
exact high frequency local structures so
the texture here so for example in the
case of the fur of the scroll
the main thing that we're interested in
is that it looks like realistic fur
but we are not really interested in the
precise locations or interactions of
these individual headers
and using this Insight can actually
really help to train better genetic
models because if we can get rid of
these imperceptible high frequency
details in the first stage
then the generative model doesn't
necessarily learn uh need to learn the
distribution over them
and because these are kind of
imperceptible details
it does not have to waste capacity on
something that we do not see in the end
anyways
this is kind of the general motivation
behind that
um and like our first work on that was
BQ gun in the paper taming Transformers
for high resolution image synthesis that
we published two years ago
and I would like to briefly talk about
this because the underlying motivation
architecture is actually very similar to
stable diffusion
so
to avoid modeling These Fine high
frequency details that would kind of
lead to wasting model capacity uh we
introduced this leaky Gan model and Wiki
gun Builds on another previous work
um
which represents an image as a sequence
of entries from a learned code book
more precisely we use the vqvae
architecture which was introduced as a
model for neural discrete representation
learning and in a nutshell this approach
relies on the straight through gradient
estimator and Vector quantization to uh
simultaneously learn the scopebook and
the encoder anticular modules which are
convolutional neural networks
and after training this first stage
model this V2 vae this um
will produce a compact discrete
representation of an image from which to
like you can take the image and code it
into that discrete representation and
decode back into image space from it
but uh vqvae as it was introduced relied
only on Pixel wise losses losses such as
L2 or L1 losses
and
um using only that is not kind of using
enough domain knowledge about images
because if we do that and reduce the
capacity of the code book too much then
um we will have this typical blurry
reconstructions and if you want to do
high-res image synthesis we of course
want to get we we don't want to be
bottleneck by having blurry
reconstructions
and
um to kind of overcome this issue
um we actually need to avoid an
objective which favors a perfect pixel
wise we can reconstruction and would
lead to averaging and um blurring
and
even more crucially if you want to put
the limits of compression and learning a
nice discrete representation
um
we
um we want to learn something that only
captures the more Global structure and
gets rid of this high frequency details
that I already talked about and to to
ensure that
um we introduced like two
additional
losses to the original bqvae
um architecture one is the L clip slots
which is a perceptual loss so
is a perceptual loss which has been
demonstrated to align well with human
perception
and then the other thing that we
introduced is a epithelial training on
top of that so we uh introduced another
discriminator which actually is um
trained in a patchwise fashion so let's
use local patches of of the
reconstructions of this VQ gan
and
this ensures that we actually enforce
local realism and don't have blurry
reconstructions
and this means then that the total loss
of this model is actually a combination
of the Leaky laws
um that is used to train the cookbook
the Reconstruction laws and the
adversarial laws
and because initially we found it
extremely difficult to actually
correctly uh weigh these terms so we
introduced a more Dynamic strategy uh by
the way to to weigh in the episturial
loss by calculating in the depth of
weight that we then apply to this of a
serial term and this adaptive weight is
simply the gradient
um
of the Reconstruction loss with respect
to the last layer of the decoder divided
by the gradient of the serial loss with
respect to the last day of the decoder
and this means that the contribution of
the adversary loss is decreased as soon
as the gradient of the Gan loss is
larger than the one of the construction
laws
and another important part of it is that
we actually warm up the training first
by by training only with reconstruction
and weekly laws and then as soon as the
model has already converged to some
something that looks like good
reconstruction that is not necessarily
like high uh realistic we then add the
atmosphere with objective to it because
this is kind of the more
we found that this is the most stable
way to do to train this model
and yeah as an illustration of what this
actually gives us we can look at
reconstructions of this uh scroll that I
would talk was talking about as a
motivation so uh if we look at this paw
of the scroll here we see that for a
standard discrete vae which is not using
perceptual loss or at the serial
training
we see that the old structure is
actually good
um but the local details are blurred out
and the texture of the stone is not
crisp so this does not look like a
realistic image I would say like a
realistic natural image and when we
instead train the speech again Paradigm
that I introduced we
uh with like the same latent capacity
um we achieve a very good reconstruction
and realistical contexture
and what this additionally gives us is
that we can increase the compression
level even further and we still have a
realistic uh looking fur of all the
posts and shape is not perfectly aligned
with the input anymore
um okay so this is basically the first
stage training and then this work like
in taming Transformers We were training
um Transformer models as the generative
model in the second stage
and uh to do this doing this is actually
really straightforward so uh once we
have the video game trained
um you and code your training images
through the encoder which gives you this
um discrete grid of code book entries
you enroll them into a 1D sequence and
then you can train an auto recessive
Transformer on the sequences kind of top
left to bottom right
and it's also easy to make this model a
conditional model like a text to image
model
and one way to do that is to just
pre-pend the conditioning tokens so text
embeddings for example 2D sequence or
you could also use an encoder decoder
structure to do that and then use the
Transformer to model the distribution
over the discrete entries and then
decode with the pre-trained decoder back
into English space
so yeah we use that mainly to um
generate these uh high-res images of
Landscapes uh because we were kind of
compute uh bottlenecks while being at a
research lab but it's actually pretty
cool that Google through this approach
and
used uh slightly modified version of
vqan which is based on Vision
Transformers
and trained a large-scale text to image
model and they showed that this actually
is scalable I can produce really good
looking results and I think the latest
version of that is actually combined
with the Imagine upscaler to produce
really impressive uh High Press images
okay and so so this was kind of the
the first work in that direction the
second was then high resolution image
synthesis with latent diffusion models
and it
it shares the motivation with which you
gun basically so
um what it it
kind of you can kind of view this as
um exchanging the Transformer backbone
with a diffusion model and this gives
you a certain advantages which I will
talk about in a bit
um but one more thing is that
um you can train this on a VQ um
embedding so on a discrete embedding but
the more natural way maybe to do that
which also gives you slightly better
reconstructions in the first stage is to
use a auto encoding architecture which
does not have a discrete bottleneck so
not a vector conversation layer but a
but is which is regularized with a KL
loss so it is also could be used and for
your training stable diffusion and we
just use a very slight uh regularization
to still have
good looking reconstructions with good
texture
but it ensures that the latent space is
not arbitrarily scaled
but like adding the adversarial loss
with this uh
Dynamic weighting and so on this is
exactly the same as a week again
but there's one more thing that we
needed to do to um because we were
interested in text to image generation
to actually make
diffusion models work for text image
generation there was no um architecture
at this point which which did that so we
came up with this uh modified
architecture we took opening eyes ADM
model
which was trained for class conditional
synthesis on imagenet and
this model came with our self-attention
layers in the unep backbone and we kind
of replaced these self-attention layers
with one layer Transformer blocks which
are themselves which themselves consist
of self-attention cross attention and
feedback feed forward layers and these
cross potential layers helped or can be
used to condition on arbitrary inputs
kind of so one of them is like the
natural way to to conditional text is I
would say cross-attention so you you can
use this to condition on the outputs of
some other text encoding model
um which you can either train jointly
with the unit or you can also use a
pre-trained one
uh like flipped like a clip text encoder
that was used in stable diffusion or
something five encoder or anything else
um yeah and these are some some text to
image outputs that were actually then
um
generated with stable diffusion so
stable diffusion is an instance of a
latent diffusion model that uses this
architecture that I just introduced uh
stable diffusion users a fixed clip text
encoder to do that
and yeah I didn't generate these samples
I collected them from a Discord server
because their people who can do this way
better than me
um but yeah it has been really
impressive to see what people can
actually do with this model and one
maybe one important uh kind of
ingredient that I didn't mention yet is
that
these models only work when they are
combined like work well uh only when
they're combined with something that's
called classifier free diffusion
guidance
and this is kind of a cheat code that
was introduced by Jonathan Hall and Tim
Salmons and intuitive explanation of
what it does is during the diffusion
during the denoising process it pushes
the model away from an unspecified or an
unconditional model towards the
conditioning signal so towards the text
that you give it and this means that
this process actually needs this
unconditional model
um
which might might seem like a
disadvantage at first glance but
actually it's very easy to implement
this by dropping out the conditional
signal at a certain rate so for stable
diffusion we dropped is um 10 of the
time during training
and this also comes only uh with a small
additional cost of inference because
um these scores these model outputs can
be computed in parallel or if like your
memory restricted you can also compute
them sequentially but then it's a little
slope
and yeah here we see um some outputs uh
for
uh s equals to one according to this uh
classifier free guidance Formula One
means that this is actually the standard
diffusion case without this guidance and
we see like okay this doesn't look like
a good looking Generation The Prompt
here was a panda eating fries in a
restaurant
but if you um turn up the value of this
guidance scale we actually arrive at
something that looks like a panel eating
fries in a restaurant right so this is
super important to actually have this in
the model
but um yeah stereo Fusion is not
restricted to uh yeah it cannot only do
um text pure text to image synthesis but
it could also do in painting and the
nice thing about this is you can and I
think Justin already talked about this
is you can actually take the pre-trained
model
fine tune it for these different types
so in painting is one instance of this
you can then um because it's text
conditional the nice feature is that you
can actually control what you want to
have generated in the masked area
another is semantic synthesis
um we recently published a model that is
conditioned on molecular depth estimates
so this gives you something that is a
model that is really shape preserving so
you can give it an input image infer the
step estimate with it's actually using
another neural network and then
condition the model on that and yeah as
you can see the shapes are
um really preserved for this one
and in other words it's upscaling
which is also very easy to implement by
just uh giving it a low resolution image
and there's uh one more
um nice application which was not
possible before when doing uh the
Transformer based approach which is uh
image to image or uh
image to image translation and this is
based on something that was introduced
in a paper called SB edit
and it's a very simple recipe so given
some initial image uh you would add
noise to this initial image according to
the diffusion schedule that you use to
train the model
and this destroys some information from
the from from your your initial image
but
um then
you can actually reword this process
process with the pre-trained model and
using different text bones you can try
to steal what the output looks like
so cool thing about this is that it
doesn't need like additional training
but can just be applied with a
pre-trained diffusion model
and yeah I I did this initially with
this uh sketch here of this landscape
that I came up with and it's
it's actually really cool that you can
control the style of the Generation by
simply changing the text from so we can
do a watercolor painting of a fantasy
landscape we can do a digital artwork
um by just changing to training on Art
station or specify certain artists and
so on and yeah this was uh
I have to admit unexpectedly popular but
I think it's really cool to see that
this is can be used in such creative
ways so uh for example it was uh used to
upgrade uh your child's artwork they
work on some uh there were a lot of
interesting uh Twitter threads on that
and also yeah I just found it um
interesting how many creative
applications people came up with uh this
is not actually not based on image image
but just takes the image um but just
this text to color palette application
where you would
to just enter an emotion or some
abstract concept and get a color pull
that out out of that is I think very
nice
um application actually of text image
models
um people combine this with other
techniques
for example for video stylization
[Music]
um
then there was this there like even more
websites right now like this but the one
that popped up pretty quickly was Lexi
Carlile
kind of a library for
samples generated with stable diffusion
and you can browse it and um
check uh the hyper parameters that were
used to generate the the samples
um and try to use this as an inspiration
Maybe
um it was very interesting to see it is
uh how many plugins uh and uis popped up
and ports to tensorflow cameras uh ran
on a Mac pretty quickly it was used for
glossy image compression
and lots of interesting actually to see
it is uh being used increasingly used as
a benchmark for
um different inference engines and so on
yeah and um
what's what's next with this um I don't
know how long like this specific stable
diffusion architecture will be around
but um I guess one
one very interesting
um
Direction uh that I'm excited about is
actually uh
making this faster doing inference
because this has lots of practical
applications I think for for mostly all
of the different uh creative
applications uh that that we've seen and
one way to do that is uh by distilling
um the model into a few step denoiser
model
and yeah um actually uh happy to
announce that we are working on that
that there is a collaboration going on
with chenlin who had a nice paper on
desolation of uh guided diffuser models
and we applied that to stable diffusion
and um there's
um good performance already uh with four
steps only and this model also folds
this classifier free guidance tab into
the model based simply or by
additionally distilling the
the classifier free guidance step into a
single step that is conditioned on the
guidance scale so this also decreases
the costs actually of doing that
um then I think this is an interesting
Direction maybe it can be pushed even
further
so yeah that was my overview
um
credits uh go out to like all the
amazing collaborators Patrick Andreas
Dominic Bjorn from the research lab
um of course hiking phase for the
support
um and so on and all these open source
libraries so um thanks thanks for having
me
thank you so much Robin I really
really nice talk
um I think uh jono has some some
questions um to share
yeah well first off you headed here
folks uh distilled stable diffusion
coming soon Robin thanks for sharing
that
um yeah I guess I had a question on sort
of where you're thinking of looking next
I know you came from this Transformer
based approach first to the latent
diffusion models like you
thinking that diffusion is going to be
the way forward or has party sparked
some thinking that maybe the Transformer
approach might be interesting is there a
hybrid like paella where you could do
like a diffusion inspired like
multi-step inference with Transformers
what are what are your sort of research
interests going Beyond like
just the fine-tuning stable diffusion
yeah absolutely good question
um
so yeah I think there are two two
directions so one of them is actually a
distillation making this fast is super
interesting and then it's becoming
really hard on the few step regime and
um improving dabs making it a real-time
application I think um would be super
nice like retaining the General
generalization abilities of the original
model but having it in
having it in real time would be nice so
this is like One Direction the other is
um we see all these different
uh fine-tuned dream Booth models I think
there are over
uh 5 000 on hugging face already uh 5000
checkpoints which is insane
um and maybe it is a way of actually
getting kind of this performance without
needing to fine-tune
um so I think this is also a super
interesting Direction
right so something like what Justin is
doing where you're adding additional
capabilities of not just depth
conditioning but maybe conditioning and
images conditioning other places yeah
all right exactly
what a question from the audience if
that's okay we could share oh yes we've
got a minute or two yeah perfect
so the question is from Paul who's
asking is there like a direction to sort
of add numeracy so can you for example
have something like a painting with nine
apples and I think in general this idea
of like compositionality and you know
numeracy is kind of like a as far as an
open an open problem do you have some
sort of thoughts there about you know
how we might integrate that information
yeah I think one of the um directions is
to use increasingly powerful text
encoders I think the imagine a paper
already showed that that this is uh
possible
um the others maybe you could
you could combine this with uh
like this conditioning techniques you
could condition on let's say the output
of an object detector or something like
that which actually detects the objects
and then is able to count them and then
you could modify this by like oh just
specifying the number of things that you
want to have
so maybe these are like two different
ways of doing that
awesome
so I think it's time for your compatriot
Patrick to join the party so uh thank
you so much again Robin it's a real
pleasure to hear from the creator of
stable diffusion
you know sure and uh yeah see you next
time